welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we want to discuss
lawrence transformation or in other
words
given an event observed by bob you want
to express that event as observed by
alice you want to find the translation
between the observations and bob
reference frames to the observation in
alice's reference
they have already done this for the
classical case
as galilean transformation now we want
to do this in the framework of special
relativity
in order to simplify the discussion
uh we don't worry about the y and z
component here those dimensions can be
neglected if we assume
that
the relative motion between the two
reference frames only in x direction
we also know from the previous
discussion that you can use the
invariant interval
see t square minus x square is the same
observed in bobs and in alice's
reference frame we'll make use of this
fact
and lastly we can assume that this
transformation has to be linear why
because
we transform something like a
measurement of distance into a
measurement of distance
it has to be linear if not we find
something like a length squared or the
same for time and we might end up on
time square if we don't do this
correctly
all right so we can write this down as a
linear equation which is a
multiplication of a matrix with a vector
c t x
into a vector ctx prime x prime
okay so the goal here now is to find
the parameters or the the coefficients
of this matrix
okay
um i invite you to stop the video here
and try to work it out um it's an
interesting exercise test your algebra
knowledge um there's not much physics in
here but it's still useful to go along
and try to to work this
out so the first thing we want to do
is assume that
the origins coincide at t equals zero
and then we can follow along the
trajectory of the origin of s prime in
the s frame
so this is just t t v t
okay great this already gives us
a constraint on the coefficients a 1 0
over a 1 1 which is equal to minus b c
okay
and then we can use the invariant
interval
which is another constraint and we can
use this to obtain
the set of equations here we'll not read
this for you
and that's already enough in order to
solve the set of equations so if you do
this and follow along
you find
answers for all four coefficients
um you know given uh gamma and beta as
we defined them before this then
simplifies to our loans transformation
so the only thing we did here is you
know we simplified a little bit we
assumed that this is a linear
transformation we use the invariant
interval in order to
set the constraints and we find lauren's
transformation if i summarize this we
find this matrix here with coefficients
gamma minus gamma beta minus gamma beta
and gamma
great
or if you want you can
write this as an equation for the
spatial component and the time component
so does this make sense there's always a
chance that we make a mistake in this
kind of calculation so we want to make
sure that
the answers we developed in previous
sections actually are reflected by this
transformation so let's go one by one
the first thing we can do is check units
if we do that we see
that this first equation here
is of unit meter and then we can analyze
the the second part of the equation okay
so gamma is of its unit list
x is a unit meter and then we have
better c t
better is unitless c is meter per second
times second also of unit meter so this
checks out
the second equation is very similar c
times t is of unit meter
meter per second times seconds of unit
meter
gamma is unitless beta is unit less and
then we have an x unit meter
plus c t
c meter per second times second also
meter so this checks out so this is
great
at least you find that we have a linear
transformation
by design and the units work out
so now we can see what happens now if we
use this for velocities which are much
much smaller than the speed of light
in this case gamma is equal to zero and
beta is very close to zero
if we put this in our equations you find
x
prime is equal x minus vt and t prime is
equal to t
okay this checks out because this is our
galilean transformation so for systems
which move relative with very low
difference in velocities you can use
galilean transformation as an
approximation of launch transformation
okay at the third part now we can
investigate a little bit further
for example what happens now to a
distance
just a measure of distance or measure of
length which we obtain by making this
measurement
at
simultaneously at t1 equal to t2 we find
delta x prime is equal to gamma delta x
all right that's length contraction
if we do the same thing for delta t for
measure doing the measurement of time at
x equal x2 equal x1 we find time
relation
all right is exactly what we expect
and then we can look at two events which
happen at the same time in frame s
um and see what happens to the time as
measured in system s prime
delta t t prime is equal to gamma delta
t well in this example we set this to
zero and then we have the second term
which is minus beta over c gamma delta x
so we find that
while this event happens simultaneously
in our frame as s1 and s
it does not happen simultaneously in our
frame as prime
um there's an extra term which is uh not
zero unless you actually measure at the
very same point
um if l is equal to zero so this is the
relativity of simultaneous 80. again
this checks out and i think we're good
with our launch transformation